I was diagnosed with cystic fibrosis
when I was four months old
it's like having a cold or the flu that
never goes away and eventually it leads
to needing a double lung transplant or
you pass away
I'm Travis Flores I lived with cystic
fibrosis and I am in need of a third
double lung transplant I think the first
thing I need to say about growing up
with a chronic condition and even living
with it now is that the majority of
chronic illnesses are invisible and you
would never know by looking at me now at
least I hope that I'm in this position
of dying
[Music]
for the most part as a child I lived a
happy normal life my parents did a
wonderful job and my two brothers did an
incredible job at supporting me and
making sure that I felt normal
I didn't quite understand that I was
sick until the moment I was in the
hospital but when I was a teenager I
started coughing a blood and that was a
real turning point with my understanding
of this was going to take a toll on my
life and it wasn't going to be easy and
that I had a condition that by
definition could shorten my life and
without the third double lung transplant
I won't survive
when I went through the first transplant
and I survived I decided I can't hide
Who I am
it gave me an eye-opening to who I
needed to become cystic fibrosis for the
longest time I've said I don't live for
it I live with it and I think there's a
difference there and I used to say that
it didn't define me as well but I
believe that given the fact I have
survived and overcome so much I think it
does in a wake to find who I am a lot of
times people try to put adjectives in
into association with me like
inspiration or brave you know all these
amazing words that I'm very very humbled
by but I really believe one of the
strongest adjectives about myself is
cystic fibrosis survivor I think that's
important but I'm proud of that
the second transplant really is where
things changed and it was because I had
a very close encounter with death in
2017 I was in the hospital I had to
collapse loves tubes in my chest
every breath was labored
[Music]
I told my mom to get the nurse I knew
what was happening I was going to die
and that moment it was now my mom even
knew I think she got up in the middle of
the night and she didn't hesitate she
just got up and she didn't break eye
contact with me it was like she needed
to make sure I was okay every step she
took really the last thing I remember
saying was mom I'm sorry or something
like that and then I'm dying and I just
let go and it was the most remarkable
beautiful merciful feeling I have ever
experienced in my life
and I want to know what that was
after that longer fighting what would
have happened if I kept going when I
came through it I was different I've
just become so grateful for life and
I've realized that I don't have any
control of time so my time that I do
have I'm gonna spend it living in the
present moment and when that time comes
that I'm not here I just want to be at
peace and I want my family to have peace
because this has been a really it's been
a really long battle and they deserve
that I deserve that
I think about death everyday every
single day but the way I view Jeff is
very different I would say for the
majority of my life i associated fear
with death I definitely was scared of
the unknown and I think that that is a
lot of why people fear death I was
scared of the religious aspect did I do
everything right in this life so that I
could have this amazing experience in
the afterlife but I wish I would have
had the understanding of death that I
have now earlier because I see death as
this beautiful experience that I get to
share with every other person in this
world it unites every one of us I view
death as the neighbor next door who
constantly is coming over and knocking
at my door with cookies and I'm just not
home I don't answer the door I don't let
go and get the cookies but one day I
will open the door and welcome in that
neighbor and have a wonderful plate of
cookies and be happy I think our society
puts way too much attention into finding
absolute answers at the end of the day
life is not going to be an absolute
answer to something you know I think
life is about finding the gratitude and
beauty in every situation so that in the
end whenever that is you don't look back
and go why did I spend all that time
upset about those little things
having gone through what I've gone
through I try my best to put more of my
energy into love and I think that my
life now moving forward is all about
securing time and to have more time with
my baby niece will be a year old in just
a month for my parents my brothers and
my husband it's about that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]